et comment organiser la ville de demain
lons doit-elle s'étaler et gagner sur
les terres environnantes
ou doit-on mettre la priorité sur la
rénovation en coeur de ville christophe
bois quelle est votre vision de
l'urbanisme à lons le saunier à notre
sens il faut aller sur des deux champs
il faut rénover comme on l'est le
centre-ville qui avec des apps des
appartements qui sont vieillissants est
souvent inoccupé à peu près système et
la roma puis après on va pas être
d'accord sur les chiffres parce que
monsieur ravier doublage est vide il
double après dix jours de nouveau la
saline seuil on est à 160 vous mettez en
cause
non non non mais ils vont regarder sur
une période puisque forcément il ya
toujours il ya toujours des
déménagements et on est assis 160
appartements
ce qui est beaucoup comme c'est beaucoup
c'est beaucoup non car elle se travaille
avec l'opération coeur de vie il faut
faire ce travail et de ce travail est
commencé et que l'établissement public
foncier soit rue des salines est là
actuellement il en train d'avancer sous
les anciens locaux du progrès donc c'est
entendu nous dit pas réellement à ça il
ne faut pas que les familles qui
souhaitent et en d être des familles qui
ont souffert de d'être peut-être
certaines familles qui souhaitait avec
le confinement trouver des espaces verts
on peut pas leur interdire et de
construire à lons le saunier
si on leur interdit de construire se
soigner y'a pas de soucis ils vont aller
construire à 10 soit 15 km prendre leur
voiture pour revenir travailler à la
ville et en termes d'impact carbone en
termes de en terme d'écologie ça n'a pas
d'intérêt
les zones concernées ne sont pas des
zones protégées ce sont des autres si on
prend bojan j'y suis allé récemment ce
sont des broussailles et c'est à
proximité du centre-ville
j'arrive ravier vous vous opposez
totalement à ces constructions de
lotissements notamment à l'extérieur de
la ville c'est ça un projet de
territoire au niveau de l'agglomération
il est marqué noir sur blanc qu'on veut
arrêter l'étalement urbain projet de
territoire approuvé également par
monsieur bois donc si monsieur bois vote
maintenant de développer des idées
quartier ans bojan et rochette
il ne resterait que par l'engagement par
rapport au projet de territoire de
l'agglomération
deuxièmement il le constat il ya mille
trois cent soixante logements vacants
alors stationné de nombreux logements en
très mauvais état
je reçois nous dit
la municipalité actuelle est en train de
faire le travail il a découvert il ya
pas longtemps parce qu'avant il n'en
parlait jamais c'est depuis dans la
campagne depuis longtemps qu on met ça
sur la table au foyer municipal d'un
seul coup ils découvrent il ya des
problèmes nous on se bat sur ce problème
depuis qu'on est élu et il faut pas
laisser aux générations futures un
centre ville vidée en mauvais état je
trouve que c'est une responsabilité
vis-à-vis de des enfants et des petits
enfants et je pense qu'il faut aussi
voir l'évolution de la ville de demain
la ville de demain monsieur bois ce
n'est peut-être pas toujours d'avoir une
maison avec du terrain autour ça a été
ça dans les années 70 on est en 2020 et
donc je pense qu'il ya moyen sur un
centre-ville de restaurer des bâtiments
éventuellement d'en détruire d'autres
est de libérer de la place pour mettre
des îlots de verdure revégétaliser la
ville
c'est ça l'avenir il ya de nombreuses
villes en france qui vont faire qui sans
les petits se lance dans ce domaine il
ya des villes comme dijon qui avait
prévu un écoquartier ils ont beau donner
pour conserver des terres cultivables et
il ya d'autres villes en france
on ne peut pas dire je suis pour la
transition écologique et dire je compte
j'accepte de continuer à construire sur
des zones naturelles à un moment il faut
une fois une certaine logique